In today's video, we'll continue learning a
beautiful 400 year old lute piece that you can
play on your guitar it's called Mr Dowland's
midnight and it sounds like this [Music]
make sure you've watched part one if you haven't
already as well as my other videos on the history
of tablature now without further ado here is
part two in terms of the tempo of this piece
let's not forget the title Mr Dowland that's the
composer of the piece he's referring to himself
midnight so what does Midnight represent Darkness
depression the absence of Light which is good and
darkness which can be haunting and scary so
maybe loneliness being afraid something sad
so being a sad piece like this I think this
sort of represents Dowland's Melancholy in
fact Dowland was famous for writing melancholic
music like the famous flow my tears for example
[Music]
so in playing this piece I'd encourage you
to keep a nice slow tempo it doesn't have
to go fast because the slow speed
can sound more more melancholic in
fact slow and quiet together make
a nice melancholic sound [Music]
[Music]
Before we
end, we just have to talk about the Rhythm and
then these little dots that we see throughout the
piece in tablature the rhythm is located above the
lines and we see these flags represent different
with nickel values very much like modern score we
have an eighth note that has a little flag on it
this is kind of like that now historically these
have specific names like "minims" and "semiminums"
for the sake of ease in this introductory lesson I
just want to say we're going to simplify a little
bit to use modern language and make this make
sense we're going to think of these notes as
quarter notes so those are two chord notes the
first chord would be a dotted quarter note and
the second note would be an eighth note you'll
notice actually in this piece most of the notes
are just quarter notes so if we're thinking in
4/4 most the time we play one two three four
just occasionally we have to do something else
either eighth notes or a dotted quarter note
so to understand the first bar I like to think
one and two and three and four end the dotted
quarter note gets one and two one and two the
next eighth note appears on the end of two so
one and two and and then the next two are
easy three and four and so one and two and
three and four and now I'll do it again but
without me actually counting ready go foreign
but in your mind if you think one and two and
three and four and it'll give you the right
proportion the second measure has an easy Rhythm
it's just quarter quarter quarter quarter so
One Beat each the third measure rhythm is the
same as the first one two and three and four and
and the fourth measure is easy one two three
and there's nothing on before that's called
the half note when you have a chord last for two
beats three four that's a half note now in the
manuscript the things you see that have three
beams these we can think of as eighth notes
in other words that one and two and three and
each of those things I'm counting one then two
and three and are eighth notes so if we look at
measure eight we see one and two and three four
so we see four fast notes eighth notes and
one long half note one and two and three four
in other words in each measure
you count up to four just listen
to my recording or me playing for now to
get a sense of how it's supposed to go
now before we call it a day the last me to know
it's very simple you see dots under certain notes
the dots as we learned in my history of tablature
video in this case they refer to the right hand
fingering so one dot under a note means we should
pluck it with your index finger two dots means
you should pluck it with your middle finger it's
very common in this period to play scales with
the thumb and index finger so thumb index thumb
index thumb index thumb index kind of like a pick
in fact that's where the technique comes from
playing with a pick it's actually very fast so
now I'm going to play the piece and I want you
to watch my right hand and to get a sense for
playing the index finger and the thumb whenever
possible on strong beats to get that sense of
weak beats and strong beats good notes and bad
notes that we talked about in the previous video
[Music]
if you're enjoying this free lesson and are
serious about improving on guitar I'd highly
encourage you to check out my online music
school Arpeggiato this is an online school
for plucked instruments and if you'd like
to learn a plucked instrument like Guitar,
ukulele, bass, lute, or delve deeper into the
subject of tablature we have an assortment of
specialists in various instruments and styles
who can give you weekly lessons on Zoom so please
check out arpajato.com to learn more you'll
notice that the thumb pops down and plays a
lot of the second and the first string this
is normal in Renaissance lute music and gives
us an really nice sense of strong weak strong
weak. as opposed to [Music] which sounds clumsy
congratulations at this point you officially
know everything you need to know to play this
piece from a 400 year old manuscript now this
piece comes from an entire book of pieces in
the same handwriting I'll include a link to that
book in the description and there are countless
more books just like that available for free
on websites like imslp.org at this point you
should practice this notation more get used
to this piece get really good at it and then
once you feel comfortable start exploring that
book and discovering this music for the first
time there's hundreds and hundreds of years
of music just sitting there waiting for you
to play it if you enjoyed today's video make sure
you subscribe and hit the Bell so you don't miss
other videos I post like this one if you want
to help me make more videos like this you can
go to my patreon and there you'll find lots
of behind the scenes content about what I'm
up to the videos I'm making performances I'm
giving and you'll receive rewards like early
viewing all my videos my CDs and you can even
get a private lesson with me and lastly if
you're interested in learning the classical
guitar especially at your own pace at home
I have a beginner online classical guitar course
called classical guitar Pro it's six hours long
53 videos so I hope you'll check that out until
next time thanks for watching [Music] thank you
[Music]